and finally new rule now that I've heard
author Michael Lewis say about his
latest subject crypto Crasher Sam
bankman free that if you gave bankman
free to choice of living in a $39
million Penthouse in the Bahamas without
the internet or the Metropolitan
Detention Center in Brooklyn with the
internet there's no question in my mind
he'd take the
jail I say we finally start seriously
looking at what phones are doing to
people's
brains
wow and and not just phones there has
been a perfect storm of events in recent
years that has led the Surgeon General
of the United States to issue an
advisory that America is suffering from
a Public Health crisis of loneliness
isolation and lack of connection what
Matt Gates calls another day at
work w
and this is not just in America Japan
and the UK have actually appointed a
cabinet level position for Minister for
loneliness because the studies and the
data from around the world show that the
health consequences of so many people
feeling so isolated are staggering
skyrocketing rates of stroke heart
disease premature death it's just become
too easy to isolate now we've got our
phones and our gadgets to distract from
having an actual ual conversation Amazon
to deliver instead of going to a store
GrubHub instead of going to a restaurant
movies streaming on TV instead of going
to a theater and even when we do go out
the earbuds stay
in we can't even do casual chitchat
anymore remember when you'd roll through
the checkout line with a six-pack and a
box of
condoms you know
he'd have a little moment with the
Checker where he'd be like somebody's
having a party
huh but there are no high fives at the
self check
app we've traded going out with people
we like for going on Facebook to get
likes has anything ever been more
misnamed than social media it's done
more to kill being social than the
pocket
protector
it should be called antisocial media and
then AI came along and made it even
worse do you know a 19-year-old from
Southampton England recently breached
the walls of Windsor Castle in an
attempt to assassinate the queen because
his AI chatbot girlfriend told him it
would impress her yes there's an AI jod
Foster
now
and the idea that your girlfriend now is
just a voice in your phone just like in
that movie
Her is no longer science fiction there's
one bot cheick on the market called
replica and she has two million users
and boy is she going to be in trouble
when her boyfriends find out she's
seeing two million other
guys
everybody keeps saying how AI is coming
for your job and it may well be but it's
also coming for your
boyfriend Yuval Harari asked the
question about the future what kind of
relationships will there be when
computers and objects understand you
better than the people in your life I
don't know but it sounds like it'll be a
profitable world for the makers of
Jurgens
and if the technology wasn't making the
problem bad enough we also have a media
that is built on jinning up fear and
hostility and convincing us no place is
ever really safe poor Britney Spears
can't even dance at her own home without
a couple of
knives we've become like that old lady
from the Twilight Zone episode who hides
behind closed doors because she thinks
death is trying to get
in but here's the irony in real life
what's killing you may well be you
staying inside the overreaction to the
coid pandemic may turn out to be more
damaging than the disease itself the
strategy of social distancing and
staying home to work and staying home
from school all for very long periods of
time made us into different people
safetyism became a political identity
and now some people never want to go
back to work or school or
Venezuela too many people got used to
saying no I can't make it to your
birthday party not for any compelling
reason just for the sake of ultimate
safety well we're just now starting to
tally the collateral damage from
ultimate safety from long lockdowns and
creating four-year-old
germaphobes and they include erasing two
decades of progress in math and reading
School absenteeism as The New Normal an
alltime drug high and overdoses and
murders huge increases in obesity and
depression and the atrophying of social
skills that lead to it you know what
else went off the charts the last couple
of years car crashes they couldn't
figure out why you know what they came
up with people's heads are just so
scrambled and they're so full of pent up
rage from being locked up in the kids
home all the time and my stupid
husband so they just got in the car and
drove like a maniac and took it out on
the
road
so so to quote every mother since the
dawn of time for sake go play
outside
I know I know outside is full of
flashers and Rusty Nails and germs and
sharks and stranger danger but your
mother was right it it's actually worse
to stay cooped up magazine surveys like
to ask the question how would you like
to die my answer is anything except
going unnoticed until the neighbors
complain about the
smell
20 years ago the show that defined the
Zeitgeist was called friends today it's
Naked and
Afraid